the reason I stopped you is you had your
your hand out the window so what so what
constitutionally protected speech is it
illegal to flip off the police no but
that won't stop cops from trying to
punish you for it last year a Delaware
man was peacefully protesting a police
speed trap when several cops seized and
destroyed his sign when he flipped off
the officers while driving away they
cited him for improper hand signal but
this law applies to turning signals not
rude hand gestures the officers knew the
citation wouldn't stick and they
admitted it on camera for giving the
middle finger so
the courts have ruled that flipping off
police officers is protected speech so
the story ends well for the Delaware
protester after he filed a lawsuit
claiming that the police officers
violated his first amendment rights the
officers agreed to a 50 000 settlement
even if cops don't like it you have a
First Amendment right to tell them to
get